the bogus border the lands of the
birders they are camped on the bank of a
river that flows into the Khazar Sea and
is called the Volga they live between
the khazars and thus a caliber their
ruler called al mesh is a Muslim the
region is marshy and thickly forested in
the middle of which camps the population
they are composed of three horts the BA
Sula the ich Gill and two bogus all
living together in one place they trade
with the Khazars and the ruse who bring
their merchandise to them
the bogus who live on both banks of the
Volga offer various products in exchange
such as the pelts of sable army and grey
squirrel and other furs they are in
agricultural people who grow all sorts
of grain wheat barley and millet the
majority are Muslim and there are
mosques and Koran schools in their
inhabited places they have no essence
and amongst the infidels have the custom
of prostrating themselves when they meet
their friends these bogus are camped
three days march from the birders whom
they raid frequently and bring back as
captives they have horses and coats of
mail and their arms are superb they pay
tribute to their ruler in the form of
horses and the like when a man marries
the king takes a force when Muslim ships
come to them a tax of 10% is levied on
the merchandise they dress like the
Muslims and their tombs are constructed
like those of the Muslims
their wealth consists above all of
Marten pelts
they don't use hard cash since their
unit of exchange is the Marten pelt
which is worth two and a half Durham's
sometimes they use round silver Durham's
which they receive from Muslim lands in
exchange for their wares then they in
turn use those Durham's to pay the ruse
and sir calibre for these peoples will
only sell their goods for hard cash
[Music]
you